pro jahr bisher ja bedürfnis
ja oder nein egal maracuja
schaut ja sag mal ich hab schnell
gemacht sommer über sommerfeeling da
geht im mund hallo zusammen wir machen
heute ein leckeres nowak solero dessert
also eine art mango maracuja das ja aus
dem kühlschrank ganz einfach also
wirklich kinderleicht ich schreibe euch
wie immer alle ganz genauen
mengenangaben hier unten in der infobox
sein können durch das screenshot
einkaufen gehen und ganz easy peasy
nachmachen ich starte jetzt hier mit der
sahne die ist schön eiskalt dann lässt
sie sich immer am besten aufschlagen und
die lasse ich jetzt einfach oder die
schlagen ist einfach streifen einem
handrührgerät bei seiner geringen eine
menge lohnt sich die küchenmaschine
nicht dann nimmt er einfach ein
handrührgerät da das sich gleich einfach
noch wann fest ein riesen und dann was
ich schreibe schlagen manche schlag ist
ein
ja oder nein ja egal
die sache ist jetzt schon steigt
gekommen ist ganz kurz an die seite und
weiter geht's mit den nächsten zutaten
eigentlich sehr sehr überschaubare
zutaten nichts exotisches oder so ich
hab ihr mascarpone immer schön
geschmacksneutral wage ich mal das ist
immer super als basis um was capone ist
schön fest das heißt dadurch dass es
halt auch nowak schnitten sind und keine
gelatine benutzen ist mascarpone immer
eine sehr gute wahl und was ich auch
immer mag ist doppel raum frischkäse
dann nehme ich persönlich jetzt einfach
philadelphia geschmeckt hat der salsa
und da kommt für die süße natürlich zog
herein und für den geschmack vanille
extrakt und zitronenschalen abtrieb und
beim zitronenschale abtrieb ich verwende
ja immer bio zitrone und das solltet ihr
auch also immer unbehandelte eine
unbehandelte schale verwenden oder wenn
ihr gerade keine da hat dann gibt es
auch zum beispiel hier geriebene
zitronenschale
und kaufland oder hier zitronen passte
das auch dann kaum was drin das könnte
auch immer gern verwenden
so die masse bitte nur maximal zehn
sekunden rühren weil sonst wird die
masse sehr schnell flüssig und dann
verbindet sich alles nicht mehr gut und
ihr habt keine standfestigkeit mal so
wenig maximal zehn sekunden das reicht
vollkommen
und jetzt nämlich um einen teig schaber
und hebt die steif geschlagene sahne
unter in ein bis zwei schritte noch zwei
schritte und
heute gibt es wirklich das rezept in der
kategorie sehr einfach und sehr schnell
das ist ja das besondere auf einem kanal
gibt es mal wirklich so richtig einfache
rezepte sowie heute und jetzt zum
beispiel also es in der vergangenheit
aber am sonntag kommt soviel einfach mal
eine zweistufige hochzeitstorte online
also eigentlich ist für jeden was dabei
wenn ihr meinen kann er noch nicht
abonniert haben dann holt das jetzt auf
jeden fall ganz schnell nach da nachdem
ihr das unter gehoben habe zeige ich
euch wie es weitergeht
[Musik]
so die cremes fertig jetzt baue ich mir
meinen ba kram zusammen könnte
eigentlich auch eine auflaufform nehmen
die dann in etwa eine ähnliche größe hat
also wenn ihr traum ein paar zentimeter
variiert ist das bei no back rezepte
schlimm aber der ball kam hat den
vorteil dass ihr das dann gleich einfach
schön anheben könnte dann habt ihr
einfach
eure schnitten quasi frei stehen und bei
auflaufform ist immer so das erste stück
immer seine verzweiflung das
herauszubekommen daher mache ich das mit
meinem bugs namen dafür noch so ein
trottel jeweils unterlage da könnt ihr
irgendeine unternehmen auch gerne direkt
in eine serie platte wie ihr möchtet
nachdem mir dann die klammern
festgeschnallt habt ihr damit auch
nichts verrutscht so geht es weiter mit
dem löffelbiskuits und da kennt er das
spiel das ist ja ähnlich wie beim
tiramisu einfach für zwei sekunden in
flüssigkeit unken auch wenn das gefühl
habe das ist auch total hart nach der
schulzeit geht das alles komplett durch
weicht von der feuchtigkeit der creme
also wirklich nur 12 dann draußen kurz
abtropfen lassen und dann hier auf dem
boden lag und ich habe übrigens viel
maracuja nektar sehr sehr lecker ihr
könnt auch milch nehmen aber das ist
einfach normal next level also probiert
es auf jeden fall mal aus
[Musik]
und der vorteil unseren buck kam ist
natürlich jetzt hab ichs grad einfach
nur ein bisschen
zusammengeschoben und die nach größe der
löffelbiskuits angepasst haben eine
größe von 25 x 25 cm und jetzt kommt die
gesamte creme einmal da drauf und wird
dann schön glatt verstrichen seien
anschließend haben wir ein bisschen zeit
für uns denn vier stunden muss das ganze
kühlen und danach wird es auch nochmal
schön fest also schön schnittfest dann
zeige ich euch im anschluss wieder den
scheinbar akkus macht
[Musik]
so die kühl zeit ist oben und wir machen
jetzt den maracuja goes dafür habe ich
hier einfach nur die maracuja nektar und
werde ihnen zusammen mit speisestärke
einfach verrühren der herd es noch
ausgeschaltet und wenn es dann klümpchen
frei verrührt wurde einfach den herr
einschalten und unter ständigem rühren
einmal aufkochen lassen dann liegt
nämlich die masse ein und dann aber
nochmal so acht bis zehn minuten warten
dass wir nicht ganz so heiß jetzt auch
unsere seine masse kommt und sobald sie
ein bisschen abgekühlt ist kann er was
man an der oberfläche verteilen und das
ganze nochmal auskühlen lassen
[Musik]
heute können wir uns sind gerüstet was
wollte schon für textes hinter uns haben
frau begab und ich komme richtig leckere
video wird ja haben so einfach raus dann
erwischen maracuja es bleibt ja
einfach lecker frisch sommer nicht ganz
schnell gemacht ist echt weich geworden
dass ich hätte sogar nur drei stunden
gekühlt mails sein und in der zeit ist
es total weich geworden das
sommerfeeling es geht im mund muss nicht
mal kauen und es wirkt nun etwas weg und
wirklich auch wichtig für alle die und
manchmal schreiben unsere leute so die
sagen ja für meine oma die kann nicht
mehr so gut kauen oder so empfehle ich
solche kuchen für die uni beim nächsten
mal echt sehr lecker und selbst heftig
sehr lecker ich guck mal ich mag es
eigentlich mal so bodensee 40 wachsen
aber hier passt das richtig gut
erkennen boden backen kann man sich bei
dem das hauptsächlich spannbeton ist
aber du musst du selber gemacht naja der
nektar und speisestärke
dass ich voll aus dem konzept gebracht
ja ich rate euch das rezept wirklich mal
nach zu machen das ist sehr einfach und
sehr sehr lecker und ein rezept das auch
familienfeiern glaube ich ganz schnell
weg ist also wir uns wäre das so weg
geöffnet ja
sehr sehr sommerlich
jetzt sogar politiker und das master
oder hier abonnieren kann auch wir reden
[Musik]